– Zum Wohl!
– Danke!
– Wir haben so schon viel zu tun.
Es war ganz sicher
die richtige Entscheidung,
den Betrieb nicht zu vergrößern.
– Das denk ich auch.
Aber wir könnten unser Restaurant trotzdem
ein bisschen ... verändern.
– Denkst du an was Bestimmtes?
– Na ja.
Ich finde die Idee mit dem Lieferservice
immer noch total gut,
aber wir sollten nicht
an Privatpersonen liefern,
sondern an Institutionen.
Zum Beispiel an die Tafel,
Kindergärten, Altenheime …
– Du meinst einen kostenlosen Service
mit Zutaten, die übrig bleiben?
Die Idee ist nicht schlecht.
– Denk drüber nach!
Mahlzeit!
Was darf’s denn sein?
– Einen griechischen Salat bitte
und ein Wasser.
– Sie können wohl keine Pommes
mehr sehen, was?
– Vor allen Dingen kann ich sie
bald nicht mehr riechen.
Dieser …
Geruch nach Fett …
ist ziemlich eklig.
Aber ich möchte mich auch nicht beklagen.
– Ach bei uns dürfen Sie das.
– Ich hoffe, dass ich bald wieder
als Arzt arbeiten kann.
– Sie sind Arzt?
– Ja, in Syrien war ich Arzt.
Ich bin Urologe.
Aber hier hab ich noch
Probleme mit der Sprache.
Meine Tochter spricht schon viel besser.
– Na, da sind Sie bestimmt
besonders stolz auf sie.
– Ja und nein.
Sie macht mir große Sorgen.
– Das tun Töchter.
– Söhne aber auch!